snowfall in Western New York being
measured in feet not inches one of the
strongest storms ever recorded a
Relentless snowstorm record rainfall
record-breaking rainfall with a new UK
record temperature Earth is increasingly
experiencing extreme weather
wreaking havoc across the world
devastating ecosystems economies and
communities
when catastrophic weather strikes it's
often blamed on climate change
but there are also natural phenomena at
work
El Nino and La Nina are opposite states
of one of Earth's most important climate
processes
the El Nino Southern oscillation or Enzo
these extremes impact people everywhere
around the world but what is Enzo how
does it work and what kinds of extreme
weather do El Nino and La Nina cause
in the 17th century Peruvian fishermen
noticed periods of unusually warm water
in the Pacific Ocean
they called this phenomenon El Nino the
boy in Spanish named after Jesus as it
occurred around Christmas
it wasn't until the 1960s that
meteorologists realized that this was
linked to the southern oscillation which
refers to changes in atmospheric
pressure between Darwin Australia and
Tahiti in the Central Pacific
the two names were combined and the El
Nino Southern oscillation or Enzo was
coined
the key thing about Enzo is that there
are three different states there's a
neutral Enzo State and there are two
extreme states El Nino and La Nina
Enzo is an interaction between water in
the Pacific Ocean and the atmosphere
above
measured in changes to Sea surface
temperatures and atmospheric pressure
but to understand Enzo you've got to
know which way the wind blows
in the neutral phase winds sweep along
the Equator from east to west across the
Pacific Ocean
these are known as trade winds
they move surface warm water in the same
direction away from South America
towards Asia and Australia
the layer of Ocean between this surface
warm water and cold deep water is called
the thermocline
with more surface warm water now in the
Western Pacific the thermocline is
pushed down but rises in the east
this leads to a process called upwelling
because you're pushing some water away
to the West other water comes up from
below and this water tends to be colder
and also richer in nutrients and that's
why you have very rich Fisheries off the
west coast of South America
during a neutral phase sea surface
temperatures remain close to their
long-term average
these conditions can last for years
but they're broken if they're pushed
into one of two intense States
El Nino or La Nina
when this happens the world is more
likely to experience extreme weather
El Nino is talked about as the warm
phase of enso normally what seems to
start off in El Nino is that the trade
winds which push the water away from the
South America weaken
they stop pushing warm water West
instead it remains in the eastern and
Central Pacific
those Trade Winds can even start blowing
in the opposite direction
pushing warm water back East towards the
west coast of the Americas
the thermocline in the East is pushed
deeper and can sometimes completely
flatten out
El Nino basically kind of puts a cap on
the upwelling because as the warm water
moves back it's harder for the cold
water to come up what you find is that
the fissure is decrease because the
amount of nutrients for the Plankton
that the fish eat reduces
definitions vary by country but
generally in the middle of the Pacific
along the Equator in what's known as
Nino region 3.4
sea surface temperatures have to be at
least 0.5 degrees Celsius above average
to be declared as El Nino
and it has far-reaching effects on
ecosystems and livelihoods around the
world
scientists blame El Nino's forecasters
now say a so-called Godzilla El Nino
could be developing they fear that the
El Nino will bring yet another season of
drought areas in the northern United
States and Canada become drier and
warmer
Central America is hit by drought
and intense tropical storms also become
much more likely on the west coast of
the Americas
you get really quite wet weather in
parts of Peru you get dry weather in
parts of Brazil because you're moving
the warm water towards Latin America in
the Pacific then you are drying out some
of Asia so you're drying out parts of
Australia which might then catch fire
you're drying out Singapore but it goes
beyond that part of the tropics you can
expect to see quite a lot of rain and
thus possibly flooding in parts of East
Africa maybe something drier in West
Africa
one of the most severe El ninos in
history started in 1997.
many scientists believe the upcoming El
Nino will be even stronger in summer
already calling it in advance the
climate event of the century
it brought devastating drought to
Indonesia Malaysia and the Philippines
while Peru saw heavy rains and floods
the extreme weather associated with s El
Nino was the cause of 23 000 deaths
worldwide
thank you
the damage is estimated to have cost
between 60 to 180 billion dollars in
today's money
it also led to record global
temperatures
the oceans store up much more heat from
global warming than the atmosphere does
and during El Nino with more warm water
at the surface that effectively means
that more heat can get out of the ocean
and that's why typically El Nino years
are warmer worldwide
but after about 9 to 12 months this
phase of Enzo usually comes to an end
[Applause]
effectively El Nino gets tired I mean
the feedback mechanisms that are holding
it together one or other of them will
break down and it will flop back into
the neutral phase
hi I'm Oliver Morton I'm a senior editor
at The Economist if you're enjoying this
film you should know that Economist
subscribers get access to a wealth of
global analysis on everything from
scientific breakthroughs to
International politics from quasars to
questions of sport you can read it you
can listen to it you can watch it you
can even take part in it at exclusive
subscriber webinars
to get a subscription at a really great
price go to the link
and now back to the film
[Music]
having returned to Enzo neutral those
trade winds blow from east to west but
if they keep getting stronger they can
push Enzo into another extreme the cool
phase La Nina or the girl in Spanish
powerful Trade Winds now push even more
surface warm water West towards Asia
the thermocline becomes shallower in the
Eastern Pacific
increasing upwelling off the coast of
the Americas
more cold nutrient-rich water is brought
to the surface
a la nina event is generally declared
when sea surface temperatures in Nino
region 3.4 become 0.5 degrees Celsius
colder than average
La Nina is great if you are fishing for
anchovies of Peru because much more
upwelling so more food for fish and some
more fish
so there are silver linings to the
extreme states of Enzo but La Nina is
still responsible for plenty of
Destruction around the world
hurricanes in the Americas become more
likely on the East Coast
by early 2023 Earth had been in La Nina
for three consecutive Northern
Hemisphere Winters
which is highly unusual for a pattern
that normally lasts 9 to 12 months
La Nina was associated with devastating
extreme weather events across the globe
Heavy Rain Led to Serious flooding in
many countries from Australia to South
Africa
drought was widespread with Argentina
and China among the places that were hit
particularly hard
we've had a sort of like chain of La
Nina's mouth and I think Far and Away
the biggest human impact has probably
been the drought in East Africa which
has fed in the food security of tens of
millions of people
you could also point to the floods in
Pakistan last year which fit into a la
nina pattern and were particularly
severe
33 million people were affected and
almost 2 000 lost their lives
flood damage and economic losses
amounted to over 30 billion dollars
nine percent of the country's GDP
the fact that the the la nina made the
world as a whole a little bit cooler
doesn't mean it wasn't very hot in
Pakistan and that meant that the rain
clouds could hold more water and that
meant that the floods were particularly
intense
[Music]
Enzo isn't the only factor causing
extreme weather like this
global warming means glaciers in the
north of Pakistan are melting faster
which also contributed to the floods
so the double whammy of climate change
and the effects of Enzo can be
disastrous
one of the things that's been striking
about this recent La Nina is despite
that cooling effect the world has been
hitting near record temperatures every
year for the last few years
so with La Nina keeping a lid on global
temperatures imagine how hot Earth could
get when it moves into the warm phase
but exactly how Enzo is being affected
by climate change remains unclear
since 1950 El Nino and La Nina phases
have been getting stronger
leading to more significant changes in
sea surface temperatures
if you look at long-term records of the
climate not human records but records
from the environment you find that enso
has been varying for thousands tens of
thousands of years so it's very very
hard to say that the changes that appear
to have happened in enso in the last 50
years are definitively due to climate
change when you ask different climate
models about what enso looks like in a
warmer world something says one thing
and some say the other
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change has said there's no consensus on
whether there will be a change in
enso-related Sea surface temperatures in
The Next Century
but the one thing most climate models do
agree on is that due to global heating
Enzo's effect on rainfall variability
will increase over the East Central
tropical Pacific
so with El Nino this region will see
even more rain whereas during la nina it
will be drier than usual
over a third of the Earth's population
lives in the tropics and they face a
climate which changes from year to year
with El ninos and La niñas in ways that
other people just don't normally
experience Enzo is a terrible thing for
the tropics but it is at least somewhat
predictable perhaps the most important
thing that the world as a whole can do
about Enzo is take it seriously and move
resources to the places where they are
needed in advance of the weather pattern
one forecast is certain Enzo will
continue to be one of the most powerful
forces to influence earth's climate
if you want to know more about El Nino
and La Nina we produce an interactive
article on Enzo that shows you more
details on how it works thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
foreign